extreme weather and natural disasters
are among the most significant threats
facing the world this year that's
according to a recent survey of global
experts and decision makers hurricanes
Harvey Irma and Maria along with 13
other major natural disasters caused
more than 300 billion dollars with a B
in damage last year and that is a new
record for the United States Toni Tecopa
went inside a unique research lab
helping businesses protect themselves
Toni the video was fascinating good
morning good morning the fire lab you're
about to see is one of the world's
largest and it's just one part of the
1,600 acre FM Global research facility
in northwestern Rhode Island the
research done there is passed along the
businesses so they and the communities
they serve can bounce back faster when a
disaster strikes inside this warehouse
flames tear through two shelves stacked
high with boxes but what may look like a
catastrophe is only a demonstration
one shelf is protected by a sprinkler
system that triggers moments into the
test the other is not this feels like a
furnace right now you can see it's like
we're sitting it is really it is a wall
of fire what's the lesson the lesson
here is tested installed and maintained
protection works effectively by a
sprinkler one sprinkler this is a
distraction this is a disaster it's a
disaster
Lewis grid so creates regularly for his
clients we're in the business of
protecting businesses from every hazard
that concern so that's all the things
that Mother Nature does and all the
things that people do grit so is
research manager for insurance firm FM
Global his team believes the only way to
truly know how something will stand up
to disaster is to put it through one FM
Global uses these tests to show its
clients including fortune 500 companies
how they can better protect themselves a
better protected business is less risky
to insure this looks like something
you'd see in a house it is exactly the
same roof as you would see on the house
but there are also takeaways for
consumers this machine can test shingles
against hurricane-force winds so what do
you do to prevent a thing like that
use a shingle that's designed for those
higher wind speeds it's going to be
stiffer it's going to have a little more
adhesive do you ever have clients who
just don't believe it until you show it
to them seeing really is believable 2017
certainly created believers losses from
Hurricane Harvey alone totaled one
hundred and twenty five billion dollars
historic flooding caused much of the
damage we did a study last year with
some worldwide experts and showed that
in the u.s. the precipitation patterns
are such that extreme precipitation in
other words when it rains it's going to
rain heavier is on the rise and there's
good sound physics and good sound data
behind that so whatever the politics of
climate change the insurance and risk
picture is pretty clear the physics are
clear
and firing the physics are also clear in
this test of half-inch thick plywood you
didn't even flinch
why would sheets like this are easy for
one person to carry comfortably so
they're often used to protect businesses
and homes during hurricanes you can see
that this projectile which is moving
according to a storm that has about a
hundred mile an hour wind went right
through that half-inch piece of plywood
if there was a window behind it this 2x4
would have smashed through the plywood
and glass exposing the inside to
additional damage from wind and rain and
so the solution is get a friend to help
you pick up the one inch plywood well
there's some different solutions and if
you really have to do it yourself and
you have half-inch plywood just put up
to Luis grit so says the one natural
hazard they can't always protect against
is an ef5 tornado that's the strongest
kind one of the company's clients is a
missouri hospital destroyed by an ef5
tornado in 2011 FM Global says it paid
that claim and now the hospital has been
rebuilt with some lessons learned you
see in all these hurricanes I mean
hurricane windows they're expensive but
they work yeah yeah Wow well now you
know yeah they get the one inch not to
happen yeah yeah some of my favorite
kind of explosions there no one gets
hurt and you learn something I like what
he says is that perfect distraction not
a disaster yeah Tony thanks very
interesting